new survey found that one in five people
in the UK
would be willing to have sex with a
robot at two thousand people were
quizzed on their attitudes towards
Android
and 46 percent surveyed admitted that
they do either had sex with a robot
or not judge others who chose to have a
robot sex
I am I to me this is just the way things
are going yes people will start having
sex with robots
in the not-too-distant future in there
probably partly doing it already and I'm
laughing
error and all that I am would you et
cetera but
you know I I guess it would depend on a
robot I really can't imagine I
hi there was a general or robot from
AOII I remember that game at yeah I was
like
okay will that make sense in the context
that AI where people are not allowed to
reproduce any market the earth is too
small in Kansas them so they're
that's kinda what is that there was one
on the part in reply with everything
going on for many retirees I'll go
right now I'll so you know the idea that
it makes sense in a logical sorta
science fiction I like a to this
immediately to the intellectual would
have taken a robot as the
I you know I don't know how I could the
robot there are you doing this in Japan
I'm here already
if you ever did happen to stumble upon
any of the sex conventions from japan
girl notice from those are quite insane
an interesting you 100 K on if you
already have the money
for that then you can buy your own and
it's already happening now
yeah so there is a movement in Japan
called otaku
which the is a a movement for the rising
number of men that are opting for
relationships with virtual
limit so there that's not to say a robot
that is a virtual
but you can't move going tonight that
place it's the next step before the
before the right thing in her sex with
her about it now
how do you feel now I back at you well
we're so far off
from Jude Law it's not exactly know if
you look at these people
where they these people like a cover to
doing it yeah
are you look at these robots with
Android like they are terrifying
first evolved yeah a sec about we've
cast my my show capita
that number one rule number one
prevailing rule
is like just like break me yeah the
robot general mobile no
the rule is that they will they will
kill us and and so if you start
submitting to them
in the bedroom they are going to be able
to be much more persuasive
when the apocalypse doesn't if that
it becomes it will pass so your brother
it will just
move that present you believe the robots
will take over one now I mean
yes yes yes show so the sex would just
be dangerous because it will facilitate
it happening faster I guess yeah
the general idea well I had another idea
that came up and I was reading it was oh
wait a second that
hide it makes sense not just in this in
that context though the otaku in Japan
that you're talking about
but also what about say a country like
china
where a one-child policy has resulted in
a huge gender imbalance you know whether
more went men and their
dar una went and got on to get married
to say you got a whole generation or
more
up man who have no outlet for that so
when you got angry horny men what
happens will you get wars and stuff
may hold it bother I was the first
commercial yeah
yup bankroll thank the governor of
Khorasan
I'll take cyber not more yeah panic
attack
like Siri love it there a will then of
course this will lead to ultimately
robot having sex with robots and then
what about babies
whatever same so what about same sex
robot to go to be there
what about a robot human marriage they
they did an episode of Futurama
about robots actual marriage which was
pretty perfect but I think
if we go if you just extrapolate right
that I meet someone will fall in love
with their robot there's a guy summer
thing in the UK
that's trying to marry his computer
right now because he loves it so much
you know about sewing is that crazy to
be thinking about mister
I you know I don't think it's crazy to
be thinking about it might be premature
but eventually I think we will probably
have to discuss and figure out the
ethics of all of this I mean I
I know it doesn't about premature robo
jacking Lake Tahoe
it is right you know it hit
now is there an epidural do with you
know with relationships you know what
people abandon their relationship yeah I
did have a robot there about that never
complains never asks you hey do the
dishes
you know if i cant if you letter about
battery die if that like me like Bahamas
killing I don't like
I want yeah I mean what I sorta guys
where we see the difference between like
a flashlight
you know and a blow up doll an actual
android robot
you know is that is this like that's the
gateway drug right to Robo
well thats why im saying this is all
happening so you have the know-how other
flashlight which is basically a piece a
plastic that you can lack of where it
was the second thing is that the place
like dog better blow we had booked out
back in the a
so this is all just natural progression
it doesn't sex importer
disorderly the way I mean that it's
changed video right from
from beta masturbator to yeah
Goodell started to digital video so xx
just kinda leads the way in where we
just follow
yeah it does seem to be the thing that
that that folks focus on mostly when
they're working on technologies like
all let's not figure out a better way to
I don't know if the the world
let's instead figure out how to have
better sex you know that that the driver
much love the attack now much it for
yeah I don't I don't understand why I
why were surprised by this or anything
and if it does seem like a natural
progression I do think it's weird
you know yeah I I don't know that i'm
gonna find myself in a row over par
media you know usually the people that
are against robots at other
been secretly having it at home yeah I'm
looking at an airport bathroom grab a
robot that
maybe by the time that we have to
address the robot sexual relationships
on where the rubber sexuales at if they
call them
we will at that point B it letting dogs
get married into and to people in cats
and so by that time I won't be a big
deal